so a lot of people been requesting
something wicked this way comes which is
interesting because when the film came
out it was a major bomb it didn't even
make half of its money back and truth be
told I never even heard of it until I
was like maybe in the ninth grade
remember it's being shown in my schools
and understanding of Ray Bradbury's work
and all the kids were so excited
Something Wicked This Way Comes oh I
love that movie I was kind of wondering
how I missed it I thought I saw the
really dark 80s kids films that came out
around that time I say this to point out
that this is not a film I grew up with
so I'm not really gonna let the dystocia
factor get in the way but that doesn't
necessarily make it a bad film I just
don't think I love it like everybody
else loves it the movie centers around
two boys one named Will Holloway and the
other named get this Jim nightshade God
how does Brad berry find these
incredible names they're often seen
around Will's father who's an old
librarian and they spend most their time
just getting into trouble all sorts of
difficult boy stuff but then one night a
carnival arise I mean literally one
night it's all put together in a matter
of just a few minutes and this has been
put together by dr. dark played by
Jonathan Pryce he welcomes people to the
carnival but the boys figure out this
slowly but surely it seems to be sucking
away people's souls
apparently draining their life force and
messing with their actual age of course
nobody believes the boys story so it's
up to them to figure out how to stop
this evil monster I get the feeling even
if I saw this as a little kid I wouldn't
find it very scary but it is pretty
creative the atmosphere and characters
especially make up for the fact that the
story itself is not phenomenally
interesting or at least kind of
slow-moving
they kind of go through the typical
run-of-the-mill stuff of people not
believing them trying to convince those
that will believe them boiling the
charismatic diabolical villain all that
good stuff it's not a film that screams
exciting or super creepy it's more of a
laid-back kind of elegant film it's hard
to explain it's like the creepy stuff
doesn't come out at you and say boo it's
more building up this environment that
slowly is trying to get you without you
Ness
Sara Lee even knowing it and that the
foreground of that is Jonathan Pryce who
is just perfect as the villain he never
goes quite too over-the-top but at the
same time he's just so graceful and
loving of what he does just look at that
outfit you can tell he wears that suit
with such incredible charisma but at the
same time he's never too charming that
he's not scary a key can still look at
him and know he's the bad guy
I really like wills father in this too
you just get the feeling he's trying to
make ends meet be a good person just do
what needs to be done but at the same
time life is trying to wear on him and
he just doesn't know what to believe in
anymore this of course is a great
contrast for the kids who see all sorts
of fantastic things but have a hard time
making the adult of the world realise it
a part of me does wish it would go a
little further with its creepy imagery
and disturbing thoughts why not get a
few more monsters or go a little bit
edgier I think that's why people still
talk about films like return to Oz and
Sleepy Hollow and so forth because they
did take roots and while this one
certainly has a lot of atmosphere II
doesn't really try anything that
different okay I don't need monster
squad style violence but just something
to make it stand out a little bit more
but then again maybe you could argue
that's a part of its charm it's not an
in-your-face movie it's not a very
obvious monster film the journey and the
build-up and the suspense maybe is what
the star is supposed to be it is a kid's
film after all and after hearing all the
people that talk about and remember it I
guess it did leave a bigger impact than
I imagined it probably would it's a good
film I just don't think it's great I
think I get more sucked into the foggy
shadows that I do the actual characters
or story but they still suck me in
enough to want to know what's gonna
happen at the end if you're looking for
one of those classic intense 80s kids
films are super dark and super shocking
this probably isn't if RIA if you're
looking for something to just put on
that has a lot of atmosphere and a bit
of a creepy vibe this might be more up
your alley think something like are you
afraid of the dark except a little
smarter and more elegant check it out
next Halloween and see for yourself